within the confines of this community
center the people of dinipro rally to
the cause
the defense of their city
the defense of their homes
the building was a blur of frenetic
energy of civic activism and patriotism
as they prepare for war
at first
we were scared really scared
but now
we are ready to fight
and like fights like hell
some brought bed rests and blankets for
the army
others brought in medicine for the
internally displaced
and new recruits for the military stream
through the door
although some seem less certain about it
than others
is a bank manager with two daughters
aged 11 and four
and she's going to fight are you
prepared to use a weapon
uh
these budding recruits will hand over
their details and wait for the call
citizen fighters in a nation which is
rapidly mobilizing and the army has
hundreds of thousands to draw on
this is an extraordinary thing a
spontaneous army forms in the middle of
the city although many here have little
or no military experience but it doesn't
seem to matter
the russians have a very strong military
ukraine above all they cry
national pride fuels donations and
possible recruits
and it provides people who are ready to
make arms
around the back of the center residents
got together to make molotov cocktails
they're messy and they're fiddly they
take time to make but their efforts are
approved by the ministry of defense
i i worry that a lot of people
can lose their lives
we're not afraid to die for our
ukrainian land
[Music]
the reality of war draws in on this city
a crucial transport hub in the east
and the people who live here know they
may need to fight and die for it
john sparks sky news internet dinipro